now I know that you've heard me say many
times or you've read or listened on the
tapes that loving yourself is the most
powerful thing we can do I think that
everything you think and everything you
speak goes out from you into the
universe and comes back to you
multiplied what good is a nice car if
you are full of resentment all the time
there is a law of thinking and we are
beginning to learn about it and it is
like a computer everything we give out
can help people really improve the
quality of their lives see when there's
problems we don't have to fix problems
so much we need to fix our thinking
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes and
getting and accepting yourself when I
get to a really good level then it's
like okay now we're going to deal with
this thing I say thank you many many
many times of the day often not to
anyone else I just you know thank you
that's so wonderful
see I have this one of my thoughts about
life is that only good lies before me
she's an american motivational author
she's the founder of Hay House a new
thought and self-help publisher she has
authored several New Thought self-help
books including her 1984 classic you can
heal your life she's Louise Hay and
here's my take on her top 10 rules for
success now I know that you've heard me
say many times or you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself is the most powerful thing we
can do then everything flows everything
flows beautifully I'm not talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear I'm talking
about just really respecting and
appreciating this incredible magnificent
being that we are you know little babies
know how to love themselves you were
born in pure love all of you
there's not one
Baby Alive I that I know of that ever
criticizes its body wherever says my
hips are too big you ever heard a baby
say that
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body they rejoice in it and
they love themselves they love their
toes they love everything about
themselves they absolutely adore that
they express their feelings you know and
a baby is happy you know it when a baby
is angry the whole neighborhood knows it
they're never scared to let people know
how they feel they live in the moment
and they're filled with courage and
they're wonderful and we were all like
that got to remember that you were
filled with courage and you were full of
love and you adored yourself when you
were very little I think that everything
you think and everything you speak goes
out from you into the universe and comes
back to you multiplied it's almost as
though the universe is listening to
everything you say and everything you
think and saying oh that's what they
want but most of the time we are talking
very negatively about ourselves we talk
about how awful we are we're not good
enough we can't get this we can't get
that how can the universe bring you
anything good if that's the way you're
talking so you're saying this quality of
life doesn't mean a really nice house or
really it can but it doesn't have to but
what good is a nice car if you are full
of resentment all the time and you drive
around hating everybody that's not going
to help anything it's much better if you
had an old car and you were grateful and
an appreciative of life there is a law
of thinking and we are beginning to
learn about it and it is like a computer
if you have this gorgeous computer put
in front of you and you don't know what
to do with it it's a piece of junk but
if you learn the language of the
computer miracles happen and that is
what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works miracles
happen
what you think and what you believe it's
what will come true for you your
thoughts create your life it's that
simple and when we can get that we can
make enormous changes one of the things
that I think about the work that I do
and the work our company does is that
every product that we sell or the
property that you get as a gift from us
has the possibility to change the
quality of your life to improve the
quality of your life now whether you
actually take that opportunity or not is
up to you that's freedom but you have
everything we give out can help people
really improve the quality of their
lives and that feels good when we have a
problem most of us go Oh panic panic God
what are we going to do buh buh buh buh
buh but I have something that I try to
get people to say when a minute there's
a problem you stop and you go all as
well all is well everything's working
out for my highest good and out of this
experience only good will come and I am
safe and you do this if it's a small
thing I say it two or three times if
it's a bigger issue I babble it
incessantly but all is well everything
is working out for my highest good out
of this situation only good will come
and I am safe now this gives this quiet
your inner turmoil down long enough for
the universe to find the solution to the
so-called problem see when there's
problems we don't have to fix problems
so much we need to fix our thinking and
our attitude about how we respond to
them and then you get less and less and
when when the solution comes you say
thank you you start by doing what we
call doing affirmations and that is
making positive statements about your
life that are positive and you do them
deliberately you might do them in the
morning you might do them at
you might do them at night you might do
them you know twice a day or whatever
but you do this and you let this become
a habit and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level I call it getting the
green lights from the parking places I
mean they're not huge things in your
life they can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row and you're
in a hurry doing an affirmation is
either writing it down writing it on the
wall or the mirror or using a you know
just saying it what I like people to do
is to stand in front of a mirror and do
their affirmations because there's
something very powerful about looking in
your own eyes and getting and accepting
yourself or noticing that you reject
yourself when you're saying something
positive about yourself so that would be
a very beginning way to start say in the
morning you get up in the morning you go
to the mirror and this is a big one and
it's hard for lots of people but you
look in the mirror and I say and say I
love you I really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful we do
have a tendency in the society to just
want to be fixed right so haven't that's
and that's it I want when I get over
this problem this will be it I'll never
have to deal with anything you know a
lot of us just want to stop when we hit
a safe place yeah I mean you've got a
bit of money you've got some nice
friends you have a good house to live
and you're okay you know and you think
all right that's fine I'm not going to
touch anything else but I have watched
me and how life works and for me is that
when I get to a really good level then
it's like okay now we're going to deal
with this thing yeah yeah and there's
another thing and I've learned to just
say okay what do I do
yeah don't stare leave me alone don't
talk to me about that yeah I say thank
you many many many times of the day
often not to anyone else I just you know
thank
it's so wonderful thank you and it's a
you know you find more and more things
to be thankful about we were I was
driving up today from San Diego and the
wildflowers on the hillsides are just
beautiful this year and I was thinking I
was so glad that I had the opportunity
to see them because if I stayed down
there I wouldn't have with this drive
which was you know not a driver
particularly wanted to make but it was
gorgeous if you have very strong beliefs
within you that you don't deserve good
things in your life and a lot of people
have that then there can be delays and
sometimes people say well affirmations
don't work I've done them but when
they're doing for instance prosperity
affirmations and they've done some
prosperity affirmations and they say
doesn't work nothing's happening and I
say well alright how many prosperity
affirmations did you do in a day and
they'll say three probably and they say
all right how many poverty affirmations
did you do this day and that could be
300 depending on where you're coming
from and what are is running through
your mind see I have this one of my
thoughts about life is that only good
lies before me and I've been saying this
for many years so it doesn't really
matter to me
what happens in life because I know it's
going to be good thank you guys so much
for watching
I made this video because Kyle augurs
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you aren't me to
profile next that leave it in the
comments below I will see what we can do
I'd also love to know which of Louise's
top 10 rules had the biggest impact on
you and what change you're going to make
as a result leave it in the comments
below and I'll join the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon